mais c'est facebook qui propose cela
louis roi et président de catala xi chez
raymond chabot grant thornton entités
spécialisées dans les chaînes de blocs
bonsoir en forme d'invitation
c'est un plaisir de se faire expliquer
ça pourquoi ce nouveau projet de mark
zuckerberg suscite autant à la fois
d'intérêt et de critique également en
fait je pense pouvoir le projet c'est
l'ampleur du projet qu'il faut
s'attarder je vous dirais vous savez
facebook a pris 2,3 milliards
d'utilisateurs
oui dans facebook puis à peu près 100
millions de pages commerciales
donc facebook fait dans après une entrée
grandiose que je pourrais dire dans un
système de paiement dans une nouvelle
économie directement mais on a peur de
facebook compte tenu de son hyper
puissance
il ya des craintes il ya une peur de
voir facebook
arrivé dans ce marché de la crypto
monnaie mais en fait de par la nature du
projet ça peut être effectivement
déstabilisant pour les marchés
financiers
en ce moment partis flamands tout ce qui
touche les mêmes mais encore faut
s'imaginer il ya trois milliards de
personnes qui pourraient entrer dans un
nouveau système de paiement qui est sans
frais et il ferait à l'échelle
planétaire
donc ce qui fait que ça ne vient pas
qu'un partenaire sur les ciconstances et
c'est pour ça que les etats-unis se
penche sur cet enjeu le congrès se
penche sur cet enjeu et d'autres pays
également se penche sur ce projet qu'est
ce qui est en jeu exactement en face à
de gros défis du projet c'est tout
l'aspect de la réglementation c'est
chaque pays a ses lois et règlements ce
qui touche les paiements tant que tel et
long avec un projet qui universel dont
comment le projet vous êtes en mesure de
respecter les lois et règlements faut
que ça va prend carrément des
modifications des règles du jeu est la
seule raison je voudrais à moyen terme
les messieurs zuckerberg dès ce matin on
va respecter les encadrements on va
attendre que les régulateurs se prononce
avant de lancer le libra ne sera pas des
modifications puisque intéressant ou
dernier
je viens entre autres le japon déposé
vous incarnez d'encadrement nouveau
cadre de réglementation justement des
monnaies virtuelles donc la technologie
est là pour rester la cote de toutes les
déficiences que ça apporte d'ailleurs la
semaine dernière c'était la rencontre
annuelle de la banque mondiale est
également du fonds monétaire
international est un des éléments qui
est ressorti c'est que la monnaie
virtuelle est là pour rester gare à
cause de l'efficience qu'à l'apport d'un
système financier déficient pourquoi
c'est efficace c'est justement c'est la
beauté de la blog shane en fait la seule
et c'est l'élimination des tiers la
validation automatique de transactions a
peut être fait je voudrais c'est un peu
comme l'arrivée du courriel ou du jour
la mère elle était capable d'envoyer un
courriel beaucoup déficients dans nos
communications la bloque chaîne entre
aude amène beaucoup de puissance dans
tout ce qui est transactionnel quand on
vous avait parlé de jacques ont
notamment le japon a proposé un cadre
réglementaire universelle c'est quoi
exactement qui est proposé par le japon
mais en fait c'est surtout tout l'aspect
pour justement gérer l'identité des gens
qui font des transactions ils vont
acquérir et décrypte oman et vous savez
j'ai eu quand même beaucoup de scandales
dans les dernières années on eu entre
autres le coq quadriga ou au canada où
on avait des plateformes des changes où
les gens peuvent se procurer des cryptes
homonyme et report des pansements à
craindre et règlements tic
donc l'idée c'est d'avoir quand même une
réglementation qui va être uniforme à
travers le globe
parce que pour se cacher quand on parle
de crise permanent et aucune nation
geography on peut faire un paiement
quelqu'un c'est ce même principe une
envoyer un courriel à quelqu'un à
l'autre bout du monde de façon
instantanée mais là c'est exactement la
même d'un même genre de transaction
qu'on peut faire mais lassé des
transferts de valeur qu'on fait comme
son envoyé des courriers mais la libre a
proposé par facebook et quand même et
d'autres partenaires de ce qu'on appelle
l'association libre est quand même
différente des autres crypto monnaies
comme la vitrine le bitcoin
définitivement puisque est intéressant
avec l'album moi je crois pas seulement
c'est que c'est le début de quelque
chose d'important parce que libre à
c'est le premier gros joie technologique
se lança dans c'est le premier projet où
on a vraiment une proposition d'un cadre
de gouvernance de surveillance de sept
modèles là à lithaire alors que qu'on
regarde
les bitcoins pour le nommer mais ça
c'est une crypto monique été émise la
valeur n'est basée que sur l'offre et la
demande et il n'y a pas vraiment de
cadres formels de supervision du système
bitcoin spécifiquement autres que des
gens qui sont impliqués dans la
programmation c c comme crypto monnaie
ou en tout cas une entité qui est hors
du système
or des banques centrales or de cet
encadrement réglementaire alors que la
libraire veut s'inscrire dans un
encadrement est effectivement dire ça
nous avez entièrement raison que c'est
intéressant que je pense qu'il faut
commencer à observer le phénomène de la
crypto économie le lancement on parle de
libra mais warner qui va émettre un
équivalent l'année prochaine les gros
joueurs commencent pense à émettre des
coins en fait l'idée c'est de se créer
un écosystème où on veut que les gens
demeurent dans notre écosystème en
utilisant un jeton c'est comme des
jetons ce comme des coupons comme les
billets ou et puis j'aime faire une
comparaison 2020 ou en fait de la
version électronique du dollar canadien
taille
oui c'est la même chose dont on peut
faire un parallèle ou encore un bon de
voyage un chèque voyage
ça peut être même principe novateur cela
dit facebook pourrait ne plus faire
partie de la libre ans et il a été
évoqué cela d'autant que visa mastercard
paypal ont décidé de se retirer de ce
projet d'exemple mais en fait moi
personnages courent c'est le début de
quelque chose moi pas seulement si je
crois savoir inciter les gros joueurs
pas seulement les états à agir
donc en ce moment aussi que la banque du
canada un projet de monnaie virtuelle
dollars canadiens même la banque
fédérale américaine pensait 1 m $ us en
monnaie virtuelle donc c'est intéressant
que le projet libre à moi je pensais
mais beaucoup de pression sur les états
en ce moment pour répondre parce
qu'encore une fois la technologie est là
pour rester puisque à la mine beaucoup
des fils ans dans le système financier
mon copain et voyez value est fort pour
la masse qu'on va voir dans un autre zoo
près de 3 5 ans sur une étape qui va y
mettre vraiment une manne ouverture
derrière la chine le propos du wii
motion à lille est-ce qu'ils aient
raison mark zuckerberg de dire qu' une
nouvelle crypte où monet comme celle là
pourrait réduire les inégalités
définitivement comme je le fais comme
une taie mentionné de permettre à des
gens qui ne sont pas bancarisés ce
moment d'avoir accès à un système
financier ça ça amène ou de la justice
il ça permet de
donne accès aux gens un système
économique dans l'entrée dans le système
spécifiquement et également le fait
d'avoir la possibilité faire des
transactions aussi sans frais donc c'est
beaucoup de possibilités à cet égard
merci beaucoup louis roy très
intéressant est ressaisi pour ses
explications